tours bordeaux en une heure trente au
lieu de trois dès dimanche
cela sera désormais possible après cinq
ans de travaux l'oceane premier train de
la nouvelle ligne lgv sud europe
atlantique transportera c'est tout
premiers passagers des passagers qui
n'ont pas attendu le dernier moment pour
acheter leur billet depuis l'ouverture
des ventes début avril a effectivement
on a eu un certain nombre de clients qui
sont d'abord arrivés par curiosité qui
avaient envie d'en savoir un peu plus
sur le gain de temps sur l'offre et puis
sur le sur le prix et rapidement ces
clients-là ont transformé en vente c'est
bien qu'on a vu nos ventres
croître assez conséquemment sur la
relation note principalement
saint-pierre bordeaux pour ce qui est
des temps de trajet pas de liaison
directe entre saint-pierre et bordeaux
comptait donc une heure et demie à deux
heures en fonction des arrêts à poitiers
et angoulême
pour ce qui est du prix comptez 8 à 10
euros de plus le prix est d'autant plus
élevé qu'on gagne du temps en gros on
payer un peu plus cher si on gagne 30 %
de temps mais on payera pas 30% plus
cher pour laurent mabileau vigneron à
saint nicolas de bourgueil la lgv est
une bonne nouvelle
plus rapide plus sûr que la route son
fils est lui aussi vigneron mais près de
bordeaux sera plus rapide pour relier le
tout les différents vignobles entre
sonic old boys et saint-émilion où j'ai
pu installer mon fils il ya déjà cinq
ans et surtout à part de vinification
qui suit de trois fois la semaine donc
déjà son permettra de me suivre sur
travail et de mieux le conseiller à
noter que les quatorze allers retours
par jour entre paris et saint pierre
dont 6 ou 7 directs restent eux
inchangés